plus de 500 personnes dans la salle du
théâtre espace coluche de plaisir jeudi
soir 18 février pour la présentation du
futur centre commercial
openskies ce projet structurant pour la
ville attendu depuis dix ans pour
remplacer la zone en friche de la
galerie des sablons suscite à la fois
inquiétude et espoir
je suis venu en fin de compte à la
réunion de ce soir par rapport aux
quartiers par rapport aux problèmes qui
actuellement et par rapport à l'école
par rapport aux problèmes qui va y avoir
parce que l'école juste à côté des
travaux
je pense que ça peut créer de l'emploi
ça peut résoudre certains problèmes
comme l'accès à la gare pendant la nuit
ce genre de choses
la rénovation la place du commerce et de
la venue des sablons qui va en découler
par la mairie est très important pour
les habitants
après on espère vraiment que ça réglera
aussi les problèmes de sécurité du
quartier monte on se bat depuis
plusieurs années depuis plusieurs années
le prime de drogue ce genre de choses
une structure d'autant plus attendu par
les plaisirs oies qui vaut dans ce futur
centre commercial de 32 mille mètres
carrés la possibilité de retourner au
cinéma elle va accueillir en plus des 35
commerce et six restaurants un
multiplexe d'une dizaine de salles c'est
un projet sur lequel nous travaillons
depuis plusieurs années qui est un
projet qui n'est pas uniquement un
espace culture pas culturelle si culture
est justement mais en tout cas pas
uniquement commercial parce que c'est un
projet de lieu de vie le chantier de
l'open sky est confiée à la compagnie
phalsbourg gh choisi selon le maire de
plaisir pour être réputé avant gardiste
dans la mise en place de lieux de vie
pourquoi est-ce que ça a marché c'est
très simple vous avez constaté les
énormes travaux sur le rd 30
nous sommes à l'entrée de la zone
commerciale de plaisir c'est le meilleur
emplacement nous sommes face au chant il
y aura un rond point qui va être créé
avec les deux nous allons avoir des
super en scène larchitecture va être
belle et on travaille pour nos clients
donc on va tout faire pour qu'ils
adorent cet endroit les travaux de
l'open sky devrait démarrer d'ici trois
mois
une maquette du chantier sera présenté
aux plaisirs oies en juin prochain
livraison du centre commercial prévu
pour 2018